[Music]
you know I made a mistake
obviously it cost me everything my
life's work everything I made a mistake
and I've paid the price for it
Roseanne Barr did not hold back during
her first TV appearance since her racist
tweet scandal the 65 year old comedian
was unfiltered as she sat down with Sean
Hannity on Fox News in a no-holds-barred
interview the first thing was shocked
that they were saying it was racial when
its political and I that was a hard one
to take and then everybody started
saying I was a racist which is like the
worst thing that you can call a Jewish
person especially one who like me grew
up with Holocaust survivors Roseanne
said the backlash was so intense she was
hesitant to leave her home
I was so scared to go outside as I my
god everyone thinks I raised you know
and I live on an island where it's all
brown people oh my oh hell you know
ultimately Roseanne wants to turn this
controversy into conversation
specifically with Valerie Jarrett let's
talk about it let's really turn this
into a teachable moment we need to talk
about race and all everything that's
connected to it and when asked if she
wants to return to TV Roseanne had a
light-hearted response only if there's
nudity
[Laughter]
[Music]